I gotta lie to you guys not every day
someone like me gets to review a movie
that might just be the catalyst for
World War 3 or the very least was
definitely a catalyst to an Internet
hack dick-measuring contest between two
countries kind of cool in a way
the interview so the interview stars
James Franco and Seth Rogen James
Franco's the personality to this TV talk
show he interviewed stars they talked
about Kim Kardashian's ass from Miley
Cyrus's vagina you know like that
you don't need to know but for some odd
reason people love to hear about Seth
Rogen's his guy in the control room you
know he's like his manager he's the guy
behind the guy he's the serious one he
wants to do serious news turns out the
leader of North Korea Kim Jong hoon we
run he's a fan of James Franco show in
this movie and so James Franco gets to
interview him and the CIA is like yeah
could you kill him and now this is the
movie and that's the controversy
surrounding the movie going into this
movie I couldn't help but look forward
to this movie the more the controversy
got in our faces the Morrow's like I
have to see this movie I hope to god
it's funny at that point turns out those
movies pretty funny James Franco and
Seth Rogen in this movie their chemistry
it's out of this world because they have
good contrast between the two James
Franco's hilarious in this movie he's
that hilarious douchebag he's just a
man-child
he doesn't have common sense he's just a
big idiot he actually acted more like
his brother dave Franco I mean that in
the most endearing way possible dave
Franco if you're watching this but you
absolutely are not oh really he did but
the contrast between him and Seth Rogen
was great because Seth Rogen's like the
serious one he's the ones like nah he's
the business mind we need to do this we
need do it right we need to actually
start doing the news and then after that
you just have absurd hilarity you've
come to expect from this team what I
loved about this movie is that the
controversy actually helped it in my
mind's eye because every joke about
North Korea and this movie was like whew
too soon and I love jokes like that I
love those taboo jokes to just make you
white-knuckle it first so you're like
are they allowed to say that in the
three acts of this movie the first act
was really hysterical it was tasteless
and I loved it the second act of this
movie is James Franco hanging out and
it's it's not as funny because you don't
have enough of James Franco and Seth
Rogen which absolutely established the
movie from the beginning then the third
act kicks on and third act was actually
pretty kick-ass and tastelessly funny I
mean as a win-win and there were a
couple jokes in the movie where they
were funny when they said it they were
funny when they said it again and then
this joke kept rolling throughout the
movie actually and it did change up a
couple times but a couple times they
said the same exact joke and I was like
come on change it up don't be that lazy
it was a funny recurring joke for the
first you know couple times they did it
but when you start hitting the third
floor
and feather references start getting a
little stale ultimately if the morbid
curiosity of the whole thing the
controversy behind this movie drives you
to actually watch the movie for six
bucks you can like rent it online and
watch it for six dollars know what
you're getting into this crew has made
movies before just if you enjoyed those
you might just enjoy this if it's not
your cup of tea you're not gonna enjoy
this also if the other ones were too
tasteless the fact that this is
tasteless and now it's just too real not
gonna bring you over to the side be like
you know I was wrong before but now I
really get it this movie was raunchy it
was crude it was hysterical I laughed my
ass off when the movie was done it was
like that movie didn't need to happen
but I'm really glad it did happen
because I like laughing a lot and I
laughed a lot in this movie I will say
the interview is worth buying on blu-ray
like about irony this was on the Xbox
Marketplace not on the PlayStation
Network it's a Sony movie that's a Sony
console that's just weird to the
interview have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more